[Music]
do you remember those days walking home
after a particularly bad day at school
having to deal with facing bullies the
next day arguments with friends or the
isolating thought of not having many
friends at all those thoughts clouded in
my mind during my childhood in early
adolescent years I wanted to be stronger
more confident to have fun and to go on
adventures with friends and no show
better embodied that perfect image I had
in my head than Akira Toriyama's
Dragonball it was like an event every
time an aired on TV it broke records
shattered boundaries and was the gateway
that helped me make many meaningful
friendships as a child but did his
modern successor translate the spirit of
the original beyond communicating the
story of self-improvement adventure and
friendship how was it that this anime
captured the hearts and minds of
millions of new and old generations of
fans throughout the world join me today
as I attempt to explore the complex
emotions surrounding why I loved it and
maybe even why you loved it as I dive
headfirst into the colorful messy
light-hearted action thrill ride that
was
[Music]
it had been over a decade in the West in
almost two decades since Japanese
audiences had a new Dragon Ball anime on
TV to watch with the original series
creator Akira Toriyama directly involved
unlike another anime I'm sure toy
animation Shueisha didn't expect Dragon
Ball super to take off like it did
across the world
however unlike Dragon Ball Z it's had
more than its fair share of criticism
seeing as it's one of the most popular
Japanese properties in the world and
suffered from enormous production issues
throughout to try and figure out just
what it was that attracted and kept so
many people watching and why it's so
popular I'm not gonna do that today I'm
just going to explain why I love Dragon
Ball super why it resonated with me and
how I felt about its ending and if you
guys disagree or felt something else
entirely
that's cool I mean this video is called
why I love Dragon Ball super so if you
want to disagree be sure to leave me a
comment down below Dragon Ball super is
not going to be perfect that's what I
told myself right before watching the
very first episode back on July 5th 2015
on March 25th 2018 I watched the very
last episode of Dragon Ball super that
felt incredibly strange to say just now
I mean super has sort of become an
enormous part of my life over the last
three years having watched it a week to
week writing about it and researching it
it's been no secret to me that the show
has had huge struggles during this time
on the air be it on the production side
or elsewhere the show hasn't been
perfect not by a longshot but for some
reason that doesn't matter to me
sitting beside my brother while watching
the last episode unfold before my eyes I
couldn't help but remember that during
this show has brought me on throughout
the years whether it be the ball of
anxiety and excitement I was moments
before the first episodes airing the
shock episode 5 brought to everyone
which ultimately led me to this online
animation community I'm part of today
the feeling of lying in bed is go who
screamed Kaioken trying to temper my
excitement lest I wake those sleeping
around me the countless theories
surrounding the identity of Goku black
the more crazy the better my
introduction to the Spanish side of
Dragon Balls community god bless you
ultra instinct shaggy completo and
countless other wonderful engaging
experiences that I got to share with you
all thanks to this show you
despite not being perfect while watching
the last episode I had a big dumb smile
plastered right across my face as Goku
and Frieza my two favorite characters
fought alongside one another to bring
universe 7 to victory and thanks to
things like the Internet this all felt
like a worldwide shared experience in
various countries across the world there
were giant screens set up in public
squares
[Music]
[Applause]
now don't get me wrong I can point to
numerous instances where the show
falters melts and flat out makes no
sense quite easily but I can't help but
love it all the same three years ago I
found myself working a job I hated that
ruined my health my sleeping pattern and
afforded me a little time to see anyone
in my life I was miserable
shortly after dragonball returned and
inspired me to try something new a
youtube channel I named it totally not
marked because at the time I wanted to
be anyone other than me I can confirm
with absolute certainty that's no longer
the case and I am incredibly proud of
this little corner of the internet I've
built from nothing with you guys
Dragon Ball super isn't perfect but it
has afforded me just some random guy the
ability to talk showcase and discuss
what I love with almost 100,000 people
every week through Dragon Ball I've had
the honour of making wonderful new
friendships with the likes of anime Ajay
geek Tim 101 Masako axe and countless
others so while watching that last
episode as the chaos of the tournament
had concluded and the tone began to
shift I felt a feeling similar to what
Dragon Ball Z left me with as a child
similar not identical when I first saw
Dragon Ball Z I was 10 years old
it helped me an awkward shy kid to
socialize with other people my age and
find my footing in my formative years
when Dragon Ball Z ended it genuinely
felt as though a friend had left for
good if that makes any sense
when Dragon Ball super began I was 23 it
helped me find my way out of a dark
place through hard work perseverance and
determination it made me laugh it made
me leave for my seat with excitement and
it inspired me to follow my dreams be it
cruel struggled to keep up with Goku
Vegeta is trying to catch up some boxes
saying ningún or the countless wonderful
experiences I've shared with all of you
over these last few months and years
it's been one of the most eye-opening
magical experiences of my entire life
Dragon Ball just has something that sets
itself apart from every other form of
entertainment out there for me it
without fail turn me into a kid again
and any element of cynicism or nitpick
immediately took a backseat as I was
launched into this wondrous
impact thrill ride it's not perfect but
I couldn't help it I got caught up in
the gut punching earth shattering
screaming ducing supernova that was
Dragon Ball super
you
ie without reservation loved Dragon Ball
super and no matter what way I look at
it it just fills me with happiness
I love Dragon Ball super not because I
can't see anything wrong with it but I
love too much about it to care about the
bad as the episode began to wind down
and we were greeted for the last time
with the two characters many of us have
grown up with you might have felt
emotional had been filled with nostalgia
or indifference but I couldn't help but
look on with that same wide-eyed smile I
had when I was a kid
Dragon Ball super wasn't perfect but it
was more than good enough for me
[Music]
you
I want to take this opportunity to thank
all those who helped produce Dragon Ball
super behind the scenes through all of
its hardships you are the real heroes of
this series through all of the trials
and tribulations plaguing this animated
production they managed to deliver not
only the best ending this series has
seen in my opinion but also one of the
strongest if not these strongest
standalone episodes I have ever seen I
want to thank each and every one of you
for listening to me ramble on about this
I'm not gonna say goodbye to Dragon Ball
but until we meet again Goku matinee
[Music]
you